every entrepreneur really needs to ask
himself are you doing this because you
have to be this person who exited a
company or had some sort of specific
success or or are you just doing it
because this is what you enjoy and if
the answer is the the former then don't
start a company that's the first thing I
would I would say welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I am with a friend Ron Ryder the
co-founder and CTO of Sentra an
experienced entrepreneur who sold his
company to Oracle in 2016 and went on to
invest in over a dozen new startups
after serving in unit 8200 bronze spent
15 years in various managing positions
in data engineering cyber security and
Cloud infrastructure
can't believe we're already 40 people at
Centra obviously when people are gonna
hear this you're already going to be
like 60 or 70 and so it's not even going
to be a relevant data point but but
really you know your your journey as an
entrepreneur is you know really it's
like the sort of like this
entrepreneurial dream that I think so
many of us are are looking at especially
here in sub Nation the people that
you're doing this with you oven and a
software are incredible
entrepreneurs and so
um very uh I'm very excited to hear
about your perspective on your own Tech
leadership you know a geek by training
if you will and serial entrepreneurs so
Ron if you look back really first of all
30 000 feet in the air
Ron Ryder who is Ron Ryder you know how
do you think about yourself
uh that's an interesting question
um I think you know if you ask someone
you know across the street you know who
is Ron writer I think uh you would you
would
find that time a very Central uh in the
Israeli ecosystem of startups
um a lot of people know me usually with
a a good reference as someone who is the
uh uh you know fun to work with and you
know and strong technically
um that I think what what people usually
think about me
um
the reason I think or the the way I got
to it is is mostly because
um I care about relationships
um I I meet a lot of people I I mingle a
lot I create a lot of forums and a lot
of groups for example uh one of the
things I did is uh to create a group
called yacv that had almost 6 000
members of the military intelligence
alumni
um that uh you know it's kind of a group
that helps people find jobs and and uh
sends TV to friends and and refer people
uh to one to one another
um I was kind of always and you know
trying to be kind of central uh because
it's it's I think it's a it's it's a
it's a the mental thing I have like I
just I just it's very important for me
for people to like me work hard in this
division of you know making sure that
people like me I think that's kind of
who I am
um why is it important in your in your
in your side of the Arena I mean why is
this an important part of
sort of your success says as a tech
leader these you're putting
relationships as a as a big Cornerstone
why is that well I there's the you know
the official answer in the notification
I think the the the the formal answer
the the formal answer is uh that um you
know I think entrepreneurship is very
much based on on relationships and and
connections and you know managing people
is also about relationships and and
being good with people leadership is all
about understanding people empathizing
people expecting people being good with
their real you know building
relationships and I think uh if you want
to be a good entrepreneur you have to
make it uh that people like you and like
working for you
um that's why it's important as an
entrepreneur you know as a developer
it's really not important uh but it is
important uh for for entrepreneurs or
managers uh and so forth but the
non-formal answer I would say I would
say that um it's just some sort of
mental issue I have man I don't think
it's something that you have to have you
know no one I think it it comes with a
big toll you know if you care too much
about what people think about you
it's not a not always a good life good
very hard right you know your life
thinking all the time what would people
think about me right
sure tell me a little bit about your
philosophy your leadership philosophy so
your serial entrepreneur you're going
about this journey now also with other
people who have quite extensive
experience in in managing talented
people who who is Ron not necessarily
just you know a person who cares about
relationships but is it but as a leader
what is your leadership style like
um so I uh lead by example and
um I manage people uh
by
empathizing with them uh really I would
I see what they want to achieve
and I tell them basically listen I I can
help you become what you want you know
just follow me and and trust me I know
what you need this is kind of the
message that I try to lead with
um as an engineering manager it's all
about you know Career Development uh
understanding uh uh you know what what
are the goals you know the
self-actualization goals of the engineer
usually uh and there are some
um and that kind of how I how I manage
um in that sense I think in terms of uh
being an entrepreneur in general
um
uh it's uh I I see myself as someone who
people you know want to be right so a
lot of the uh
uh a lot of people who work for me kind
of I want to promise promises I I tell
them I I talk about is you know if you
want to be successful and successful
entrepreneur you know this is what you
need to to do you have to you know come
and work for me and and see you know how
how it's being done how startups are
being done that worked for like 50
people right after 50 people what you
need to do is you need to build a
company actually build a company and and
then it becomes uh you know a a game of
culture uh you have to build something
uh you know a culture of people that you
you know people just want to join in
regardless of of my direct leadership
um
that that I would say that you know my
two cents and so tell me a little bit
about your own internal balance Ron the
the engineer on the the CTO and Ron the
leader who's who's trying to help people
you know how do you bridge those gaps
because I'm sure that also in the
day-to-day especially as you're growing
very quickly and you have experience
also in Oracle and other companies how
how are you balancing those those
different personas in the day-to-day it
doesn't sound like a trivial like a
trivial task correct because first of
all I personally I actually really like
to code it it's one of the things that
I'm uh really enjoy I really enjoy
encoding so so I have a constant uh
dilemma right between going like looking
inbound and and seeing what what's going
on in the in the technology and focusing
inbound versus going outbound and
looking outwards and you know seeing uh
uh people you know the customers uh what
you know the media uh understanding you
know how people see us as a company to
if they want to work for us and so forth
um I'm balancing between these two I
think uh it's very hard for me because
my my uh I'm kind of an introvert which
means I kind of want to focus on the
inside and make sure you know just focus
on building something right I'm a
builder but what I basically uh learned
my I found myself to do is I would I
would basically I I look at the
companies to what I'm trying to build
right so if you look at the company it's
something you're trying to build then
you're you're basically you know you
have to understand the Dynamics of the
of the world and understand that to
build a great company you have to build
a great culture and and Company is all
about people right so uh um so I really
focus on on that side
um I would say 30 of my time I I give to
actually you know working on technology
focusing on the product and everything
uh and you know 30 is more about like
building the company in terms of the the
the the leadership the culture of the
the you know management the
um just overall things and and the other
you know 30 40 uh is things that I
actually enjoy less which is to uh go
outwards right and advocate for my
company and you know I'm the first uh
sales engineer and uh you know I'm I'm I
get uh investors uh to invest in me and
and cut you know just everything that it
relates to talking to people as an
introverted you know it's not it's not
my number one thing I that I enjoy doing
but I've learned to be good at it
um so sometimes it seems like I enjoy it
but it's not that it's not what I would
if I would be born tomorrow as some as a
new person then I would just go and be a
developer right
amazing I love that tell me a little bit
about Sentra and what you're doing areas
very very cool company thank you uh so
Center is the data security company uh
we're building something called the dspm
uh uh data security posture management
solution uh basically what Centra does
uh in a nutshell is it looks it connects
to your public cloud account and stuff
in past for example snowflake
um under sets where all your sensitive
data is automatically using an agentless
approach so basically it discovers all
the data finds classifies it and finds a
sensitive data using classification and
then understands the security posture of
it and and for example is the database
secure that's holding sensitive data is
the data being copied is it being
accessed is it being is it moving
somewhere that's not supposed to move uh
and then we generate uh alert based on
policies that basically tell you that
your data is safe and secure in in your
public cloud
um we raised 23 million dollars last
year from Bessemer Ventures and orenzev
and uh you mentioned it briefly but I
have three co-founders uh you have
Leggett who is the CEO he was the head
of the cyber security department and uh
unit 8200 where I also served in the
Army you know him he was also your
manager uh and he he managed about
roughly 1 000 people uh and uh uh along
with him he's the he was the head of
unit 8200 which is about 10 000 people
uh and then yeah your coin is uh he's
the VP product and he was product
manager at the companies such as datadog
and Microsoft uh information Azure
information protection and uh the cast B
which was uh adalon
um so basically four co-founders uh uh
40 people
uh were you know already with paid
customers uh growing fast uh
yep the dream take me back to those
first days you know you're just starting
out
um what what are some of the underlying
understandings that you had about the
world as you're thinking about the
problem space the vision of what central
is representing you know as an
opportunity for the world what are those
underlying understandings that you're
bringing to the table that you know the
average person may not be thinking about
as we go in our day-to-day
so um in general what uh what I I kind
of understood is I know I want to build
a big company I want to build a company
that solves a big issue and I want to a
big problem and I want to uh be
beneficial for the world uh I've noticed
that uh there has been this huge gap in
in the world in terms of data uh that
people don't
um understand enough how much the you
know the problem of securing your data
is is it's going to be huge in the next
decade because what happens is that the
world is becoming more and more data
Centric if you know software was the
king in 2010 now a dated the new king
um everyone you know monetizing on data
understanding uh that data is going to
be the new oil and they're starting to
use it and this usage is basically uh uh
is causing a security issue because the
usage of data uh it unlike you know
infrastructure or something like that is
about copying data to places so you
start copying and copying and copying
the data and then he wants more people
to access the data because they want
more people to get new user data so your
company can be to grow faster and be and
worth more right so is it that kind of
balance between uh um you know using the
data kind of uh interferes with with the
the the need to secure the data right
because if you want to secure it you
have to make sure that it doesn't get
replicated and then no one is touching
something data which isn't authorized
um and there's a huge and growing Gap in
this world that nothing can actually
take care of there's no product today
that can automatically understand where
your sensitive data is and monitor the
functions that actually cause a
potential data leaks uh uh in real time
to understand what is going on with your
data security right so that's kind of
what we understood we started with a
problem and slowly uh we understood you
know okay what what where's the problem
right now where do we need to focus we
decided to focus on the public Cloud
infrastructure first before we go into
the SAS applications but you know
there's a big issue with SAS
applications data being copied the SAS
applications as well
um but overall the the problem was clear
people in the uh in the Enterprises do
not know where their sensitive data is
and they understand that their Engineers
have access to the data they don't want
to take that access to the to the data
they want to make sure that they keep
running with with the uh what they were
the tools that they're using and they
don't want to constrain them but but
they do want to make sure that they're
doing their job correctly and if there's
something wrong that they can fix it and
know about it as soon as possible that's
kind of work from
and it kind of sounds like this is the
type of phone that gets exacerbated over
time it grows exponentially with with
the emergence of cloud technology over
the last few years and these different
data lakes and the microservices and and
how you have different players and
different stakeholders that are
injecting sensitive data on you know on
their own consent because we believe in
developer autonomy and we want to move
fast and break things but then obviously
we're creating a world where data lives
everywhere and our ability to to
maintain in the Integrity of of of where
it is is slacking right exactly that is
exactly the problem you're solving you
pitch it very accurately the amount of
data is going exponentially the amount
of people practicing data is going
exponentially the data right now the the
most of the Enterprises don't even have
a significant amount of data for print
on the cloud even if they have Cloud
they haven't even begun to utilize it
um you know snowflake is a good example
of a driver of that but there's a ton of
SAS services that also drive that uh as
well everything the cloud World we're
including the isps and Seth is just the
beginning we're just at the beginning of
of the data explosion incredible going
into this journey after a few years at
Oracle serial entrepreneur
sold your previous startup how how are
you how did you approach this journey
differently well what did you learn from
your previous experiences that coming in
here you're saying you know what this is
these are some things that the new Ron
is taking with him
yeah so obviously a lot of things uh
yeah I think the most significant by far
uh thing that I took from the previous
startup is the way that I approach
entrepreneurship
um previously in my first startup I was
only thinking about succeeding I was
thinking about selling my company and
nothing else
and that's called the gold goal-oriented
approach
um that is not a very healthy way to
live your life because every time it's
kind of a going on a roller coaster
because every time something that makes
you feel like you're approaching your
goal gives you a high but every time
something happened that you know makes
you understand or feel that you're
you're going to get away from their goal
you you immediately get depressed from
it uh and anxious you know it it was it
led me to really bad places you know I
really felt like I lost a few years of
my life because of that
um but eventually I was lucky enough to
sell my company and it was you know
great outcome for me and for my Founders
and my co-founders and the team
um but uh what I learned is that this is
the wrong approach what you need to do
is you need to wake up every morning and
ask yourself are you enjoying your life
do you go to work happy are you doing
what you invest you enjoy and if the
answer is no then you need to change
something right so this is why I started
the company because I realized that what
I enjoy is the act of starting a company
I don't care if what really happens I'm
mentally right right I don't care if my
company uh crashes and if for some
reason in in a year from right it does
it's not something that defines me I
don't I don't feel that you know make me
less of a person if that happens and
that realization is really what I took
with me and I think that every
entrepreneur really needs to ask himself
are you doing this because you have to
be this person who exited a company uh
or had some sort of specific success or
or are you just doing it because this is
what you enjoy and if the answer is the
the former then don't start a company
that's the first thing I would I would
say you know but I did learn a lot of
things I think that the second most
important thing
um is about relationships in in your
co-founding team I think that you a lot
of entrepreneurs go into a relationship
that they don't really uh fully realize
and understand what they're going into
um the extent of their job as well as
the extent of the relationship that
they're building with their co-founders
really getting into a a company and
getting you know co-founders is is not
less than marriage really it's it's
legally and conceptually it's kind of
the same uh you have to really really
really love and appreciate and respect
and admire the person that you are
working with you have to uh regive uh
said it very interestingly he said that
if you see the person calling you and
and it makes you happy
when you see that name this then it's a
good but this is your co-founder if you
see that the name you know if you see
him calling you you have this feeling
that you don't want to answer right now
that's not your guy right so make sure
that you you know want to marry your
co-founders before you you start a
company and of course I could say a
thousand more things but uh I can only
imagine and I just love how how
intentional you are about this whole
thing and it sounds like you're you've
done a lot of work and you know
internally also to understand what type
of leader do you want to be and you're
you're clearly defining your priorities
from you know working with the people
that you're developing and and your you
as a tech leader you as an engineer uh
the the different stages done your
entrepreneurial career and obviously the
conviction that you have with Sentra and
what and and not just the interesting
problem space but the way that you're
approaching the people that you work
with choosing the right co-founders and
so I'm taking with me from this
conversation a lot of the the great
advice but at the same time
the intentionality that you bring to a
lot of these questions that you're
raising here which obviously every
person will have a different answer but
at least the act of asking them sounds
sounds quite important so Ron thank you
so much best of luck with Sentra I
really appreciate your time I'll let you
go back to running an amazing company
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
very much
thank you
[Music]